hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
natural killer t cell or nkt cell
which is a mixed character of t
cell and natural killer cell they are
kind of a hybrid
now indeed these cells were actually
named in a transgenic mouse to describe
the t cell subpopulation which has a
characteristic symbol of
nk cells from that time this colloquial
term
was used as a nomenclature for these
cell types
let us look at the properties of nkt
cells the surface markers
and what the function of nkt cells in
this video
so nkt cells have alpha beta
t cell receptor which is similar to a t
cell
it has nk 1.1 receptor which is
characteristic of a
nk cells perforin and granzyme
containing
vesicles can be found in the nkt cells
it also have fc receptor
which binds to the fc region of
antibodies
and are very crucial for uptaking
oxinized pathogens
just like t cells they also secrete
cytokines
so this is a comprehensive overview of
their features which are similar to t
cell
or nk cells now let me tell you that
nk cells differ from other kind of t
cell
though they have a t cell receptor which
is alpha
beta type but these alpha beta t cell
receptors have very less diversity
in terms of recognition and they don't
recognize
mhc class 2 rather than they recognize
limited a variety of lipid or
glycolipids present
on cd1 molecules which is a non
classical mhc like molecule so this is
the major difference between a nkt cell
and a th
cell because th cell always recognize
pathogens or pathogen-derived and
antigens on top of class 2 mhc whereas
nkt cell
determines only few or limited varieties
of lipid and glycolipid
which is presented to them on top of cd1
molecules
this is the major difference of that now
nkt cell seems to be essential for
various aspects of immunity especially
in mouse models or transgenic mouse
models where
nkt cell production was abrocated in
those mouse model the risk of autoimmune
disease
has increased so obviously we can
understand the pres
involvement of these cell types in
autoimmune responses or to prevent the
autoimmune responses
nkt cells secrete varieties of cytokines
which leads to diverse function so let
us look at some of them
so it secretes il2 il4 interferon gamma
inter tnf alpha il6 etc
il4 and interferon gamma
are polarizing cytokines interferon
gamma
and il4 helps in production of
th1 subpopulation of t cells or th2
subpopulation of t
cells so indeed nkt cells can direct the
differentiation of t helper cell into
specific sub population
moreover tnf alpha and il6 are
characteristics
inflammatory cytokine so they take part
in
inflammation as well now nkt cells have
fc receptors
so they can really
go and engulf opsinized
viruses or any kind of oxonized pathogen
with their
fc receptor so here you can see
they can go and bind to the fc region of
oxinized
virus and literally endocytose or
phagocytose
that virus and that is how they can
neutralize the virus
moreover these cytotoxic cells eliminate
targets
infected with intracellular pathogens
such as bacteria
and viruses also they are
critical against tumor cell
immunity so the immune immune response
against
tumor cell is orchestrated by the nkt
cells
and especially when there is a
temperature associated trauma
these nk t cells are found to be
activated
still what is the exact mechanism it's
still unknown
but these are the overall functions of
nkt cells
in terms of immunity now let us talk
about
how these nkt cells are developed the
nkt cells
are developed in the thymus just like
the t helper cells
inside the thymus the imagio t cells
come inside by high endothelial venule
they move into the subcapsular region
and in the cortex and corticomedulary
junction they interact
with thymocytes which give them
essential training in terms of
antigen determination now the double
positive stage has
both cd8 and cd4 core receptors
it's a stage of t cell development
now these double positive cells can
interact with class 1 mhc or class 2 mhc
and depending upon what type of mhc they
are interacting with
they differentiate into several sub
population for example
the t cells or double positive t cells
which are interacting with class 2 mhc
they become
cd4 positive t helper cell whereas the
t cell subpopulation which is
interacting with class 1 mhc they are
becoming cytotoxic t
cell now from these double positive t
cell another variety could be generated
which is
nkt cells so they come from almost
common lineage and
it is also reported that not signaling
is
important for commitment of nkt cell
lineage
just like any other t cells so they have
lots
a lot of similarities with t cells
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share
and subscribe to my channel thank you